hey 42 here the universe is everything
there is nothing else at least as far as
we know there are theories that say
there are other universes and our
universe is part of a much larger
multiverse this very well may be true
but so far we don't have strong enough
evidence to back up such theories it is
however common knowledge that the
universe is expanding this is undeniably
true scientists have observed the
distance between large objects in space
such as galaxies and have found that the
distance between them is increasing they
all seem to be moving away from each
other this leaves only one plausible
explanation the universe is expanding
this means that all the time new
space-time is being created and the
physical size of the universe is
actually increasing just like blowing up
a balloon let's just hope this one
doesn't go and bloody pop on us so that
leaves one inevitable burning question
if the universe is expanding what is it
expanding into it's the universe
expanding into a much larger multiverse
like some astronomers say or are we all
inside a giant pigeon pie let's find out
the answer to this age-old question
depends entirely on whether the universe
is truly infinite or not if you
subscribe to the theory that the
universe is infinite than the answer to
the question what is the universe
expanding into can only be nothing
because of the universe is expanding
then that means new space-time is
constantly being added it's just like
the construction of new real estate in
space but the universe doesn't have to
apply for planning permission before
this new real estate is a brand new area
of the universe that galaxies can occupy
but you can't add new space to an
infinite area because it's infinite it
continues forever it has no end no
boundaries and no measurements so if the
universe is truly infinite then the
universe is expanding into nothing it's
as simple as that
well it can be simple if you sweep all
that bloody complex mathematics under
the carpet and just don't look at it but
most people have a really difficult time
understanding the concept of infinity
and we have an even harder time
understanding the concept of nothing
just try and think about nothing for a
second you can't it's impossible you're
thinking about thinking about nothing
and that in itself is not nothing it's
something kittens and now you're
thinking about kittens my point is the
human brain isn't sufficiently equipped
to understand these concepts it just
doesn't have the necessary tools but
that's okay because you may not need to
let's imagine for a minute that the
universe is finite it has boundaries it
may be flat round or some weird-ass
doughnut shape but that doesn't matter
let's just pretend that we know for
certain the universe has an end and we
can step beyond that wall and see what's
on the other side by the way this is all
totally theoretical now because the
current most widely accepted notion
within the scientific community is that
the universe is infinite what that means
the answer is just nothing and that's
pretty boring so let's say it's not
after all the concept of an infinite
universe is just a theory and theories
can change or be thrown out the window
at any moment so the universe is finite
and it has a boundary what would be on
the other side well you've really opened
the floodgates now you've let all the
wacky weirdo nutjob scientists with
their theoretical physics degrees and
science fiction fetishes in and they
have endless theories seriously there
are so many different answers to this
question you'll want to travel to
another dimension when you've read them
all but let's put our objectivity hats
on and take a look at a couple of the
more popular theories out there one
theory is that we are living inside a
black hole some believe that every time
a new black hole opens a new universe is
created at the other end of it for a
long time it has been theorized that
objects known as white holes exist and
they are essentially the complete
opposite of black holes a black hole
sucks in matter whereas a white hole
spews out matter like making a smoothie
and leaving the lid off the blender to
put it simply [ __ ] gets messy the theory
states that anything that enters a black
hole eventually finds itself being
spewed out of a white hole somewhere
else completely different within the
space-time continuum but if white holes
do exist they will be extremely unstable
and would only last for a few seconds
before disappearing unlike a black hole
which is considerably more stable some
people believe that the Big Bang was
actually a white hole like an exit from
a black hole within an oi universe yep
that's right our entire universe and
everything we know could have been
created as a result of a star dying and
forming the black hole in another
universe or possibly even just very very
far away in our own universe which would
mean that we are living inside a black
hole and our universe is expanding into
an even larger parent universe but
that's just one theory another popular
theory is the multiverse theory which
states that our universe is just one
universe amongst many over
ll universes like a stack of flat disks
and our entire universe is contained
inside just one of those disks if this
is true then our universe is expanding
into whatever space is surrounding our
universe and our other neighboring
parallel universes
sadly the truth is we currently have no
idea what if anything lies beyond our
universe that's because of the universe
is finite and it does have a boundary
then we can't detect that boundary
because with our current technology we
can only see so far into space this is
known as the observable universe the
observable universe is a radius
surrounding us in every direction which
is 93 billion light years across the
light from everything inside the sphere
has had enough time to reach our galaxy
in the 13.8 billion years at the
universe has been in existence but the
universe is expanding so it's highly
probable that we will never be able to
see beyond the observable universe
because objects beyond the limit of the
observable universe are moving away from
us that means that the light from those
objects hasn't reached us by now it
never will so we may never be able to
detect the boundaries of our own
universe if they exist and unless we
find that boundary we can never know for
certain what lies beyond
but science and technology is rapidly
improving and nobody knows what
mind-blowing discoveries that previously
seemed impossible will become very real
in the near future so always keep an
open mind I'll never stop asking
questions because if it weren't for that
then the human race wouldn't be where it
is today
thank to the view subscribe for more 42
you